that's it okay let's go first to our
caller from the 404 area code who's
calling today from 2004
hey David this is Grayson I'm a
first-time caller can you hear me all
right yeah what's going on Grayson hey
so um I just want to thank you for
getting me out of the right wing echo
chamber so I'm like 13 and I like really
I watch your show a lot and I think I'm
well-versed okay I just want to thank
you for doing all that we just had
another your you're 13 and you've
already had the time to be pulled into
and back out of the right wing echo
chamber oh yeah so like I probably got
like mildly interested in fifth grade so
that was in out the 2016 election and
those a lot of you were 11 years old and
you got pulled into the right wing echo
chamber oh yeah it's crazy so kind of
started with like since I've watched
like video game videos and then it was
kind of just like the SJW rekt lib [ __ ]
stupid owned with facts and logic uh-huh
I'd lose basically what whose videos
were you watching that was a lot of ben
shapiro louder a Crowder james Allsop
which is a smaller guy but he's just
straight-up racist um so up until you
were 11 what were your political beliefs
like when you were 8 what were what were
your political beliefs I I don't know I
mean my I guess my parents were moderate
Republicans like they don't like Trump
they're kind of they kind of like Romney
they're kind of more less now after like
we've talked and openly discussed so I
kind of just had someone like in their
mind you know what I mean by just
hearing them talk so then you but they
were he were 11 and you got pulled into
the right wing echo chamber and then you
were in that for two years yeah about
two years and about I say a lot of fifth
grade and then I say about seventh grade
I started like watching your show
Kuklinski secular talking now I like
it's my second day of eighth grade and I
stove's walk in your show so it's been
about a year and around there were you
like an an cap when you were five or
what were your beliefs back then oh like
act like I mean well I forgot to mention
this I was just not gonna take too long
I kind of like right coming
out of like the old right-wing like like
authoritarian right it kind of went into
libertarian right and like the Mises
Institute and stuff and then I was it
was like just very brief period I was
like libertarian and then I just got
more moved like a less libertarian
around there yeah and today was your
second day of school mm-hmm yeah it's
great yeah part of what part of the
country do you live in I live in Atlanta
Georgia and school starts this early
there huh actually um last year my
school started August 1st and we get out
in late May Wow Wow well we have we have
brakes dispersed among them um so it's
it's nice alright and do a lot of your
classmates follow politics um no I mean
night I'll talk about I have a few
friends I like really understand it and
we talk and we I mean none of them are
like probably like a political junkie
how kind of I am so well yeah how do you
I've had the more you think the capital
gains tax rate should be raised or
lowered or um well so yes to some extent
you know I mean I mean right what it
should be long it down it should go up
to like some extent maybe maybe not
exactly to the if so let's say we do
raise top marginal tax rates maybe not
to that level cuz I I know I know I know
it won't necessarily just discourage a
lot of investment but you do want that
investment like my dad my parents a
divorce my dad does like he's like a CEO
and he you'd probably mentioned he'd
probably want to do as a lot a lot of
investing if there was rates but I don't
know maybe that was just and talking but
I mean definitely you're 13 you're sure
you're 13 years old what year were you
born 2005 September 20th alright alright
fair enough
well listen this time we're going on
YouTube I appreciate the call very very
interesting wait can I ask one more
question real quick sure sure as someone
from Boston I am sort of like trans and
stuff what's your like what's your
verdict on the T or the MBTA my verdict
on it in what sense I'm just like do you
think it's a bad Transit System
you ever use it at all or you know I got
around Houston it's it's it's old the
red line is pretty solid most of the
year the blue line supposedly is good
but I've never taken it because I just
never go anywhere that it goes the the
Green Line is a total mess and the
orange line is hit or miss but you know
I mean yeah it's fine it's a fine
transit system for an old city yeah I've
been to Boston once and I love it
alright thanks for taking my call
bye all right take care yep 13-year old
13 year old grayson from atlanta very
very interesting in any any number of
different ways